la boutique le riz c'est une partie café
qui vous accueillent pour boire du thé
du café tout plein de jus de fruits une
partie vélo ventes de vélos neufs qu'à
ses accessoires
cela faisait longtemps que l'idée lui
trottait dans la tête en 20 ans je vous
avais fait le tour de son métier de
graphiste dans une agence de
communication
il voulait être indépendant pour lui
c'était le bon moment pour monter son
magasin autour du vélo et bien ici on
propose un petit endroit un peu cosy
pour se reposer après les kilomètres au
bord de loire quelques rafraîchissements
du café bio du thé et un petit espace
derrière pour se rafraîchir et poser les
affaires ce qui permet d'aller visiter
le vieux tours et la ville sans à temps
complet de sacoches et forcément de son
vélo après deux mois de travaux la bicic
lurie a ouvert en mai 2018
juste avant l'été propice aux balades à
vélo on à 50 mètres de la loire tous les
touristes de la loire à vélo
seront amenés à passer par le vieux
tours donc à un moment où données
passant par la place de la victoire et
pourquoi pas s'arrêter à la bicyclette
alors moi ce que j'aime bien c'est de
repartir sur des vélos anciens les
remettent en état alors soit l'état
d'origine ou si vraiment le vélo est
trop ancien est trop abîmé
s'en servir comme base pour faire un
casse tête pour avoir un vélo atypique
et
unique à partir de vieux cadres josé les
revisite les améliore pour faire par
exemple des fixie ces vélos urbains à
pignon fixe une passion où l'on ne
compte pas ses heures
comme pour la rénovation de ce vélo des
années 20 trouvé dans une poubelle et
tout rouillé à l'origine il expose
maintenant fièrement dans son magasin